So, Lauren just mentioned that depression is a very common symptom of war
veterans. So, let's move on now, and talk about major depressive disorder. But
before we do so, remember that there's a continuum in all disorders. So from
the everyday fluctuations to the disordered. Same is true for depression. In
fact, think also about what's happened in your own life when something bad has
happened. maybe you failed an exam or a boyfriend or girlfriend broke up with
you. For me, it was in 2009 for instance, when my mother passed away, I was
really upset for quite a while. But these things are not necessarily
depression. They're normal everyday fluctuations. So what are the criteria for
major depression? And for that we're going to move over to Lauren and she's
going to tell us.